Meguru Batura loved soccer.Whether he was
asleep or awake, he spent his days kicking the ball all the time.He
especially loved dribbling.  Meguru believed that nothing
in this world could be the best and more
fun Let's go home and play a game Why?  Hey, I'm
kinda scared, let's go with a bobbed hair, it's
weird, is
n't it?  Yo
Meguru
just can't feel what they can feel So what
should I do?  You
just have to live by believing that As you grow up, you all want
to believe, but you
can't believe it So while you're pretending you can't hear, you
can't really hear your own voice Meguru is
trying to believe  That's how
ephemeral and precious
it is, it's the voice of the monster inside my heart.